[Musique]
david di nota bonjour bonjour vous êtes
écrivain se mettre docteur en sciences
politiques et vous publiez j'ai exécuté
un chien de l'enfer c'est une enquête
sur la mort de samuel pâtit que vous
sous titré d'ailleurs rapport sur
l'assassinât de ce noël pâtit peut-être
un beau avant de commencer pourquoi ce
terme de rapport vous savez le terme
officiel le titre officiel du rapport de
l'inspection générale ces rapports sur
les événements survenus à confluences au
collège du bois donne pour être
exactement pour être précis et le nom de
samuel bâti n'apparaît pas
moi j'ai raconté l'histoire du point de
vue de samuel pâtit d'où le titre
rapport sur l'assassinât de sa malle
pâtit donc vous avez un rapport qui
prend le point de vue de
l'administration et mon souci c'était de
prendre le point de vue de l'individu
singulier qui a vécu c'était preuve de
rigueur et de quoi alors on va parler
évidemment du livre peut-être un mot
quand même des commémorations qui vont
ont eu lieu un nom de de l'assassinât
des assassinats de pâtes il ya deux
thèses amener ceux qui disent bon ça
s'est plutôt bien passé il n'y a pas eu
de l'événement dans les lycées dans les
collèges et puis et puis d'autres qui
sont plus sceptiques d'abord des
enseignants qui disent bah oui on a
quand même toujours peur de l'enseigné
la laïcité dans ses disques abeille skb
on s'est dit ça mais elle pâtit ensuite
on entendait des mets
bien un député par exemple de france a
soumis mais voilà peut-être pas montré
des caricatures et à des enfants le
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine qui
dit on le qui en demandent est ce qu'on
devrait donner le nom de samuel pâti au
collège des eaux c'est peut-être un peu
trop tôt il ya encore beaucoup d'émotion
quelle est votre réflexion à vous s'ils
ont surgi au fossé 2 pour faire très
simple pour faire très sympa ce qu'il
faudrait détaillé jacques réaction et
c'est vrai qu'elles sont tout à fait
instructive mais pour faire très simple
je dirais qu'on est face à l' ambiguïté
fondamentale le à l'occasion de ce type
de cérémonie on peut rendre hommage pour
tourner la page et pour oublier leur
hommage pour ne pas trop parler des
détails de ce qui lui est arrivé
exactement ou bien on rend hommage pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui lui est
arrivé exactement afin que cela ne se
reproduise pas et qu'un autre professeur
ne passe pas par la même épreuve et je
pense que vous avez là 2
tentation et qui sont d'autant plus
fortes la volonté de tourner la page est
d'autant plus forte que le traumatisme
était très important alors revenons à
votre livre c'est un livre très très
précis et le mot rapport n'est pas
innocent dans ce livre ce qui est très
frappant c'est ce que vous dites au fond
de deux états d'esprit vous pourrez
appeler la machine de l'éducation
nationale une fois eu un renversement
des valeurs qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ben
c'est plus quand il ya un conflit c'est
plus l'élève à qui on dit bah tiens toi
bien en gros c'est au professeur con con
qu'on va reprocher faire des reproches
c'est absolument juste je dirais que la
contradiction qui est au coeur de mon
livre c'est le fait que cette on a
demandé à semelle pâti de s'excuser pour
une rumeur créé par une élève qui
n'était pas dans la classe comme si
c'était lui qui est comme si c'était la
victime de la rumeur qui devait en
quelque sorte s'excuser de la rumeur qui
le calomnier je rappelle simplement pour
la clarté
le contenu de cette rumeur qui est
extrêmement grave qui consistait à dire
que sa mère pattie avait exclu les
musulmans les élèves musulmans de sa
classe parce que musulman donc cette
rumeur qui faisait de sa mère pattie un
islamophobe va évidemment créer une
dynamique infernale et mon livre
consiste à décrire décrypter décortiqué
l'attitude de l'éducation nationale face
à ce que les anglais appellent un
testing c'est à dire une façon quand les
islamistes de tester vraiment une
structure pour voir si elle craque et
comment elle peut craquer alors essayons
de 1 sur 2 d'aller plus haut fourneau ce
que vous démontrez il ya cette notion
doerig mais qui existe c'est le d'abord
pas de vagues oui bien sûr bien sûr ce
qui est arrivé à sa malle pâtit je
dirais que c'est la face tragique
visible de l'iceberg mais cette
transaction qui fait que le professeur
est toujours
la variable d'ajustement lorsqu'il ya un
litige toujours ce que j'appelle moi le
fautif idéal c'est un long processus qui
vient de très loin donc effectivement
c'est inscrit dans cette danse est
longue tradition malheureuse de
l'éducation nationale et
samuel pâtit évidemment a été la victime
de ce processus là et si on va plus loin
encore alors aussi tes délires des
textes officiels de l'éducation
nationale qui disent pour les
professeurs doivent établir un lien de
confiance oui avec les élèves ces
cétacés etc sans dire quand on y
réfléchit bien parce que met tout à fait
le propos d'un porte et ça c'est
d'enseigner c'est d'apprendre vous avez
tout à fait raison et je dirais que
c'est pire que ça c'est qu'en fait c'est
un nouveau jeu disciplinaire ou celui
qui juge le bon comportement du
professeur c'est l'élève donc si vous
voulez et ça c'est un carnet très
concrètement ça paraît très abstrait
drissa pédagogiquement mais ça c'est un
carnet très concrètement par si vous
prenez l'accusation qui a été adressé
par sa hiérarchie
qu'est-ce qu'on lui a reprochées au
moment même où il était la victime d'une
cabale d'islamistes a orchestré par un
fichier s
abdel hakim sefrioui
qu'est-ce qu'on lui a reprochées on lui
a reproché il faut reprendre les termes
d'avoir froissé ses élèves donc en
quelque sorte c'est l'élève le ressenti
mais non il faut aller plus loin même le
ressentir religieux de l'élève qui
détermine le bon ou le mauvais
comportement d'un professeur laïque vous
voyez l'aberration pédagogique que ça
représente mais derrière c'est ab gage
aberration il y a un vrai enjeu
politique évidemment et on va y revenir
mais c'est en effet cette atmosphère qui
explique neil explicable nouveau c'est à
dire qu on est concerné et l'éducation
nationale et les et les islamistes et
les théories vont prendre au sérieux le
bon sens de cet élève à mai mais c'est
tout et c'est toute l'horreur de la
chose je dirais c'est que le paradoxe si
vous voulez du référent laïcité c'est
qu'il confirme la thèse de l'élève qui
n'était pas dans la classe et qui dit
qu'il a offensés tous ces élèves et il
infirme le témoignage des élèves qui
étaient dans la classe qu'ils disent
mais pas du tout il ya une très bonne
ambiance et c'est donc ça c'est le
paradoxe qui est au coeur de mon enquête
à la autre chose que vous montrez qui
est assez effarant c'est que en effet il
ya des plaintes de parents d'élèves
qu'il dise des élèves musulmans ont fait
l'objet d'un traitement raciste mais
pire encore il ya des collègues
qu'ils disent ne peut pas traiter des
enfants comme ça parce qu'ils ont une
religion une autre religion que la
religion musulmane c'est ça c'est tout
le monde pendant l'heure personne ne
s'est pas attardé sur un mensonge c'est
exactement ça alors il faut pas
généraliser certains collègues oui bien
sûr voilà ça mais c'est vrai que parmi
toutes les accusations auxquelles sa
matière a dû faire face celle d'une
l'une des plus douloureuses a
certainement été l'accusation de deux
collègues qui sans vérifier le contenu
de la rumeur sont montés sur leurs
grands chevaux et ont commencé à
condamner moralement le professeur pâtit
alors même que la première des choses
c'était de savoir si c'était vrai ou
faux et au fond ça accentuer encore le
climat de solitude
construite administrativement de samuel
paty et on est dans ce que vous appelez
d'ailleurs le ravage de la suspicion de
la présomption de culpabilité parce que
c'est ça c'est exactement ça la rumeur
porte sur une accusation d' islamophobie
et
elle a été renforcée
tragiquement par les différents acteurs
et quand je dis différence est bien des
acteurs qui ont des rôles différents
c'est à dire il ya l'administration et à
l'accusatrice c'est-à-dire l'élève ya le
rôle des islamistes qui a le rôle des
parents tout ça il faut leur est
constitué mais tout a été dans le même
sens pour accuser un homme innocent la
principale me demande d'ailleurs de
faire des excuses et d'ailleurs il le
fait c'est ce qui est la preuve qu'il
n'est pas aisé pas jusqu'au bout
d'histoire une extrémiste au contraire
c'est pas du tout le contraire même
c'est tout le contraire ce quelqu'un qui
voulait absolument bien faire son
travail c'est je pense que le mot qui le
caractérise le mieux je répète toujours
cette expression de spinoza qui me que
je trouve très belle probité un signe je
pense qu'il a simplement fait preuve
d'une très grande probité et que son
geste de prévenance s'est retourné a été
construit après coup par des islamistes
en
comment dirais-je en gestes d'accuser
commandant stigmatisation en
stigmatisation raciste envers les
musulmans ce qui est évidemment une à
mensonges éhontés mais qui a été
répandue sur la toile avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît il à dire
un certain sens de l'humour parce qu il
divo l'année prochaine je parlerai de la
censure d'internet en chine comme ça on
voit on ira pas et vous raconter
d'ailleurs que l'année précédente il
avait parlé des caricatures de jésus et
ça n'avait posé aucun problème
strictement aucun problème mais je vous
avez absolument raison de parler de
cette plaisanterie parce que vous savez
les plaisanteries en toujours un rôle
capital c'est elle qui désigne
véritablement les rapports de pouvoir
lorsqu'on envoie son rapport son rêve
lorsqu'on lui on dépêche sur place un
référent laïcité
se mêlent pas tiqué beaucoup moins naïf
qu'on a essayé de le faire croire
comprends très bien la fonction de se
maintenir en effet cette blague qui
consiste à dire ok je parlerai plus des
caricatures de charlie hebdo
je parlerai l'année prochaine de la
censure en chine c'était évidemment une
façon de dire je sais très bien ce que
vous êtes en train de faire vous pouvez
dire vous citez d'ailleurs une phrase
que vous aviez équipe dans un autre
livre mais qui est très importante elle
est très intéressant de tous les hommes
sont égaux mais ceux qui n'ont pas
d'humour sont plus égaux que d'autres
bon c'est toute la culture du respect
de courir c'est quand même important
mais c'est un sujet fondamental c'est un
enjeu fondamental
mais en tout cas je voulais samson
ouvrir trop aller trop loin dans cet
enjeu qui effectivement un fondamental
je voulais insister sur cette
plaisanterie de sympathie qui montre sa
lucidité en vérité il était à la fois
très lucide sur la cabale des islamistes
qu'ils nomment nommément 1 c'est
quelqu'un qui nomme les choses donc il
dit les islamistes locaux donc qui la
cabale des socialistes pour perturber
son cours sur la liberté d'expression
et puis il est aussi très lucide sur le
rôle pour le moins ambivalents de son
d'administration qui l'accusent au
moment même où ils auraient besoin
d'être défendue mon pseudo alors
continuons sur cette administration
parce que ça c'est absolument presque
incroyable il ya donc les blondes a
parlé des parents d'élèves on a parlé de
quelques quelques collègues mais il ya
pire que ça
se sert de ce faux témoignage
l'inspection une inspection qui va dire
qui reprend la thèse du mensonge on dit
voilà il ay hilare plus le lien de
confiance avec les avec les élèves là
c'est même très c'est presque une seule
reprise les tirs ce rapport parce que et
dit oui il s'en est pas aperçu un chat
est pas aperçu ma femme voilà il s'est
mal conduit c'est ça exactement vous
avez parfaitement compris le livre est
bien vu la boucle que je décris c'est au
fond vous avez donc la situation
quelqu'un qui est pris en chasse par des
islamistes et un référent laïcité qui
confirme la thèse de l'élève qui n'est
pas dans la classe donc qu'il aurait
effectivement froisser ses élèves qui
est une thèse pédagogiquement
absurde mais qui va être c'est ça qui
est incroyable qui va être
validées par le rapport de l'inspection
générale donc l'inspection générale
reprend la thèse du référent laïcité
donc je dirais presque validé surnom
publiquement sans se rendre compte de la
contradiction pédagogique que ça
représente parce que si effectivement
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure le
comportement d'un professeur dépend de
la sensibilité religieuse de ses élèves
il n'y a pas d'enseignement laïque
possible donc l'inspection générale
reprend somnambulique mans la thèse du
référent laïcité qui en plus se repose
sur un témoignage qui est celle de
l'élève qui n'hésite pas dans la classe
entendons en tout cas confirment ce faux
témoignage et va être repris sauve nom
publiquement par l'éducation nationale
puisque l'éducation nationale va
s'appuyer sur ce rapport donc vous avez
une boucle incroyable où personne ne
s'aperçoit 1 que la thèse initiale est
faux c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas froisser
ses élèves et 2 que le fait de lui
reprocher sa est une contradiction
pédagogique donc là on est vraiment dans
l'absurdité la plus la plus profonde oui
c'est ça là le rapport dit oui il a eu
il a du mal à percevoir son erreur c'est
ça il a commis son honneur j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que ce serait une
affirmation qui serait d'un du plus haut
comique si elle n'était pas le tragique
dans ces conseils du réveil cette fin
tragique ouï
dire c'est ça qui était bon que des
terroristes se servent d'un morceau gta
pour pour aller seul évidemment ça parce
que les évêques la musique la vérité
mais et vous citer beaucoup kafka
d'ailleurs un de ces mondes y est vive
mais c'est totalement kafkaïen que
l'administration de l'éducation
nationale se servent de ces mêmes propos
qui sont fous qui sont un mensonge oui
vous savez il ya une phrase merveilleuse
de kafka qui résumerait même toute son
oeuvre c'est la procédure se transforme
en verdict et la procédure qui a mises
en accusation petit à petit un
graduellement c'est cette gradation que
j'ai vraiment des cris parce que ça
commence par des parts par des scènes à
presque anonyme un bon boeuf voulez bien
vous excuser etc oui bravo
et puis on se rend compte que sept
premiers ce premier appel va avoir des
conséquences très graves parce que on va
profiter de cet appel pour dire vous
avez reconnu votre erreur donc
maintenant vous allez la reconnaître et
donc vous avez une un processus comme ça
qui est maqué pas oui kafka en tout cas
ensuite évidemment le déchaînement des
réseaux sociaux
avec avec we abdelhakim sefrioui qui est
alors venu un fichier office grs connu
onu et russie qui va devant le le
collège filmé en disant qu'il ne nous
respecte pas ça c'est le troisième
accusateurs celui qui le traitent de
voyous m'a dit ce voyou doit être
renvoyé de l'éducation nationale et le
père est le bras mc bride ces voix-là de
la jeune élève monteuse donc qu'a
d'ailleurs reconnu après coup sur six
mois plus enjoué mais qu'il acquit duel
a aussi
dit c'est qu'il va livrer lui alors je
crois que c'est le 7 octobre c'est
sarkozy le nom de samuel paty et le le
lieu il a eu évidemment un rôle capital
si vous voulez tout vous savez
l'islamiste fonctionne par le
renversement accusatoire donc j'ai lu
très attentivement les postes facebook
de même c est surtout les commentaires
c'était extrêmement instructif et donc
sont toutes toute sa version commence
par incroyable mais vrai
et donc il va raconter une thèse fausse
évidemment on a exclu des élèves
musulmans parce que musulman etc donc il
va répandre ça mais je veux toujours
attiré l'attention sur le fait que des
parents d'élèves de confession musulmane
ont refusé de rejoindre cette cabale et
il faut saluer leur courage et leur
lucidité voilà ça c'est très important
parce qu'ils ne sont devant absolument
tomber dans le piège identitaire que
leur tendait les islamistes
alors il ya en effet oui un certain
nombre de banques qui sont entre
guillemets bien couvert oui mais
absolument on sait pas entre grêle se
sont remarquablement conduit alors il ya
des chaînes grandeur des réseaux sociaux
il ya on atteindre mais c'est vrai que
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce drame terrible
qui la décapitation sur la peine de mort
quoi telle qu'on la pratique
pratiquer
ça serait il est accusé d'avoir diffusé
des dd des images pornographiques de ses
élèves et objets des récents expliqué au
commissariat et c'est d'ailleurs là
c'est le 13 octobre c'est une scène
capitale qui bizarrement n'apparaît pas
dans le rapport ou samuel pâtit dis très
clairement je n'ai commis aucune
infraction dans l'exercice de mes
fonctions c'est vous dire que lorsque le
référent laïcité essayer absolument de
lui faire reconnaître une erreur donc
une chose faut savoir qu'il aurait
offensé ses élèves ben voilà ça n'a pas
marché ça mais elle pâtit reste tout à
fait prob par rapport à sa démarche et
c'est très important de rappeler ses
mots à lui parce que dans le rapport
tout est toujours rapportés au style
indirect
s'il indirectes c'est un style très
confortable
on sait que les sondes état d'esprit
dans ces jours là on sait que par
exemple il ne prend fin il prend très
très mal les accusations de ses
collègues et qu'il évoque un huissier
parce que l'allégation de de racisme
portées par deux collègues avant même de
rêve vérifier le fait que la rumeur 20
inconsistance de la rumeur est pour lui
quelque chose de très grave et qu'il ne
vivrait pas de façon très grave quand on
n'est absolument pas raciste comme
c'était le cas évidemment de ce mal bâti
et tout ça fait qu'on va arriver à ce 16
octobre avec ce détail qui est terrible
aussi c'est des élèves qui vont désigner
hands off le la victime c'est le
vu qu'il ya un jean et une chemise rouge
oui quelle quelle ironie pour une petite
somme trois cent cinquante
150 euros à
g j'ai du mal encore à qualifier cet
acte en réalité des élèves effectivement
attendu pour voir comment on allait le
châtier pour reprendre le terme des
islamistes et donc il ya une sorte de
curiosité pour le moins malsaine qui
s'est mis en place
certains éléments attendus 2h01
que samuel pâtit sorte pour pouvoir le
désigner deux heures c'est très très
long donc il faut quand même moi je ne
sais pas comment qualifier cet acte non
c'était mais en tout cas je les décris
sens le seul e on the rough la 2 qui
donc l'assassin on
sait à peu près d'où il vient qui il est
on sait on sait peu de choses de lui on
sait ça prouve en cette chose très
ironique pour un état français qui
accusaient d'être raciste qu'il a été
accueillie que sa famille a été
accueillie pour lui éviter les
situations voilà un tchétchène d'origine
tchétchène pour lui éviter les
persécutions alors qu'il est de
confession musulmane donc ça c'est un
très très ironique que devraient méditer
tous ceux qui accusent l'état français
de racisme alors on sait comment il
s'est procuré les couteaux à evreux vous
la raconter il ya aujourd'hui je crois
16 personnes qui sont inculpés dans
cette affaire le père de la delà de la
jeune élève
paraît-il ce
dans une
posture de victime désherbage savais pas
où j'allais pas démenti
il ya dans les commentaires vous savez
dans les commentaires des ces postes
facebook il y a quand même quelqu'un qui
a écrit cette histoire c'est trop gros
c'est pas possible j'y crois pas il
avait tout le temps de se poser les
vraies questions lorsqu'il on lui a
proposé de d'échanger avec sa mère
pattie il a refusé c'était une campagne
d'islamistes ces gens là savaient très
bien ce qu'ils faisaient
le train veut dire c'est un propos qui
est très important dans votre livre que
ce que vous écrivez vous dit samuel
patiner pas morts pour la liberté
d'expression il est mort de
l'antiracisme islamistes oui je voudrais
préciser ce point cessé cette recette un
point importante important pour ce n'est
pas un martyr il n'a pas voulu mourir
pour la liberté d'expression je crois
qu'il faut se tenir à distance dessous
c'est ce discours martirio logique
auquel on a eu droit lors de la
cérémonie officielle je crois qu'il faut
il faut il faut fuir l'émotionnel pour
rester dans l'analyse et ou alors le
symbolique pure qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
l'analyse nous apporta à démontrer que
ce qui s'est passé en réalité quelle a
été la posture victimaire des islamistes
c'est de dire
on nous a traités vous savez il ya une
phrase incroyable quand sefrioui dit si
on avait été juif on nous a reçus tout
de suite on nous aura pas fait attendre
un puisqu'il connaît lettre reçue par la
principale et le baril battu voilà donc
vous avez le victimise grave et
l'antisémitisme très présent et puis
alors cette logique toujours qui
consiste à dire et puis bien sûr la
confession j'allais presque oublié
l'essentiel qui est la vie la vidéo de
l'élève qui a menti et qui se présente
vraiment comme la victime on ne nous
traitent pas nous musulmans comme les
autres en fait dit elle donc là vous
avez bien une posture victimaire qui va
comment dirais-je précipité l'engrenage
idéologiquement sais pas si c'est pas un
fait divers c'est un c'est un engrenage
qui s'inscrit dans un dans un
environnement idéologique très
particulier où le victimise un rôle très
important
dire vous vous il ya tout un chapitre
sur sur l'islamisme
parle aussi des nodules muria vous déjà
oui par qui était qui était l'ancien
porte parole des indigènes de la
république oui et il veut citer 1 1 un
chercheur qui s'appelle philippe
d'iribarne wii
qui explique qu'au fond le fondu du
combat des stadistes pourraient dire
qu'il ya deux choix pour les musulmans
soient ils rejoignent des infidèles soit
ils vont dans ce combat peut-être pour
identité un
nom mais bien sûr je crois qu'il faut
pas se cacher qu'il y a une volonté de
déstabiliser mais vous savez pas
simplement la france pas simplement la
laïcité française moins de un point sur
lequel j'insiste toujours c'est que le
même chantage la même pression le même
testing le même un tentative
d'intimidation s'est déroulée en
angleterre on était quelques mois après
donc un professeur a fait un cours sur
le blasphème et à contextualiser
comme ça mais elle pâtit le la
caricature de charlie hebdo je rappelle
que cette caricature faisait partie du
programme oui dans ce qu'ils étaient
venus chercher
voilà d'ailleurs d'ailleurs l'éducation
nationale ne lui reproche pas d'huile ou
d'avoir montré la caricature il faudrait
pas se tromper de cible et lui reproche
d'avoir froissé les élèves bon à mon
sens c'est pire mais enfin ici encore on
comprend bien pourquoi c'est pire mais
la même chose s'est produite en
angleterre avec le même tentative
d'intimidation et le professeur a dû
être exfiltré
alors si vous voulez si c'était un
problème lié à la laïcité française a
pas ça ne se passerait qu'en france or
c'est un problème qui se déroulent
quasiment dans les mêmes termes partout
en europe donc c'est incontrôlable de
neutraliser voulait dire exactement si
c'était la laïcité parce que non il
s'est passé aussi quelque chose d'aussi
absurde c'est que du fait que samuel
patty est été décapitée on a mis la
laïcité française en procès
donc c'est ça aussi ça participe de
l'absurdité de la chose et donc en
parallèle avec l'angleterre c'est que si
c'était la laïcité en france ah bah ça
ne se passerait qu'en france tout
simplement or ça se passe bientôt en
angleterre à l'angleterre qui a des
principes complètement opposée à la
france 1 du point de vue de la laïcité
qu'à une religion d'état par ailleurs
vous citez la formule de gilles kepa le
djihadisme d'atmosphère qui est présent
dans l'enseignement dans l'université
notamment oui ça ça aussi oui vous
pensez que c'est très présent mais c'est
extrêmement important ce concept est
extrêmement important pour comprendre la
responsabilité de ce que faisait bras mc
et
sefrioui il est à dire vous laisser
courir une rumeur
sans vous engager directement vous
salissez le nom d'un homme et puis vous
attendez que quelqu'un passe à l'action
on peut pas on ne sera utilisé ce terme
on peut pas utiliser l'accusation d'
islamophobie innocemment ça n'est pas
possible on sait que cette accusation
tue on en a la preuve
peut-être une dernière question qu'on
n'ose à peine posé parce que je vous en
prie et aime sauter raison les mais est
ce que est ce que la mort de samuel
patty a servi à quelque chose eh bien
écoutez là encore on revient en fait à
la première question je dirais qu'il y a
deux possibilités
il ya une possibilité entation très
forte du point de vue de l'éducation
nationale de tourner la page pour
oublier les circonstances exactes et la
responsabilité directe de
l'administration dans la non protection
de
du professeur pâtit et puis il y a aussi
peut-être je l'espère la possibilité de
méditer ce qui s'est passé pour que un
autre professeur ne passe pas par le
même cauchemar le même enfer mais ça ça
suppose qu'on décrive honnêtement le
plus précisément possible ce qui est ce
qui s'est véritablement déroulé est ce
ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans mon
livre
je